point of view right yeah why why would
he wait for marriage or for long term
with a girl that has given it up for
free before he shouldn't so then how
would how would that work right because
maybe like I don't know how long you
waited or what but like like she slept
with four other dudes no why would a guy
like wait for a girl that slept now what
we're trying to say is that it's not the
matter of waiting right right it's the
matter of that 4 or 18 for me it's
disgusting yeah
so what she needs to do she needs to
hold it down so as she keep that full so
as she gets like bro 25 with that same
four then she can stop again right right
don't add any more to it because she's
got too much already right okay I agree
that's what I mean she can continue
after she reaches 25 because 24 at 25 is
all right yeah but you know what you
know what you know what happens is
though yeah is this
it stays at four and then usually
Jenny's on your back
but no but check it check it but then
she'll meet some guy and say your body
counts 20 these times she meets the guy
and she'll tell the guys [ __ ] but she's
gonna like it right now she's on social
media like the thing is yeah the world's
big you know I mean like you could go
[ __ ] Manchester tomorrow meet some
guys
you can't really like the world's big
the world's big you meet a girl in a bar
tomorrow you don't know where she's from
what and she's from we don't know you
don't know any of our backgrounds you've
got no you've got no mutual friends
you've got no mutual friends he's got
200 followers on Instagram on on private
do whatever I mean like you're not gonna
know her background or her past you know
I mean she could tell you anything so in
reality nobody knows really yeah there's
hell Amanda a wife he's girls right now
the worst person
another first person to live with if you
really tell a big big lie the worst
person that you can live with is
yourself
because every time she goes out there
she will have a really good brain to
remember to lie all the time or either
that or she were telling herself all
right but you were telling herself she
was able to end up lying and getting her
so caught up or she would end up telling
us
I genuinely think like
okay if you're gonna be I think the
reason guys say that is because they're
not with girls that long anymore like
how many people have really I know I
think you said you an eight-year
relationship but that's not common right
like how many people are really together
long term 20 30 40 50 years if you're
with a girl for 50 years you think she
can keep that secret for 50 years you
don't think anything will come out you
don't think you'll run it I don't think
so especially you don't think her
friends might say something because her
friends are the ones that know okay so
so hold on one second yeah how much
woman there you know give Man kids
that's not theirs and mans are finding
out years and years later woman like
that seriously the wicked like that's
the thing that you guys should watch
it's called wicked Matrix of women's
yeah women's I've give men kids that's
not their kids in it you're right you're
right you're absolutely
no no you're you're absolutely right
women can and do lie my point is that
the truth usually comes out eventually
because because the thing is like if you
if you hoe around for too long you can't
run from yourself you can't you are who
you are you are are your habits so if
you have the habit of sleeping around
for 10 15 years like you're gonna you're
gonna go back to the streets eventually
your friends your friends are gonna slip
up like the the crazy stories you told
your friends someone's gonna say
something like you don't think like
girls talk and eventually [ __ ] comes out
go ahead the thing is though they're
Extremes in it like if it goes you slept
with like 15 guys or whatever she meets
a guy she really likes tells him oh my
body counts for right she's not gonna
confess that she's really 15 and her
friends are not going to beat it up
because it's not that much of a big deal
because like most guys like when I was
when I was dating like I was going I was
meeting girls going on dates every
single girl I met said I've not had sex
in three months oh that's the word
every single time
but it's the same thing and for me I was
like I've heard this so many times so I
know you're lying you know what I mean
but again
like if she adds 10 more to a body count
and by the time she's 25 26 meets the
one she could tell the guys 47. I ain't
gonna know I just I'm a big believer and
the truth comes out eventually and
someone's gonna say something where
you're like that doesn't add up or what
she said I think most girls or you might
meet someone that you know that that it
comes out that he slept I just think
eventually go ahead he had his hand up
before okay go ahead okay it doesn't it
doesn't thank you
no it doesn't always come out because um
I don't know if you like guys watch
stand-up uh comedy much like Chris Rock
said uh men tell the most lies men men
lie to most women tell the biggest lies
and um a guy you know a guy or girl can
go through a whole whole life you know
when like uh
you know you know the woman will be
she'll lie and say I'll bet you know the
baby's yours and um
so you guys can start crying
but I think in this day nature like
especially with social media and
everything yeah like it's harder in it
like I don't think you could get away
with as much nowadays especially
nowadays yeah girls want to be posted
like it's a big thing for a girl like so
whatever you ain't said once you get
posted specially if you're like nowadays
everyone's bait that a lot of people are
big okay so nowadays you get posted you
go out you got friends everyone's
connected by what four or five years
nowadays you might not find out about
every one of the body count but you will
find out about enough where it's like
yeah yeah all right you get a chance
you post a new girl enough and like you
can tell from the people you know um
so I mean you'll see you'll see if
you'll see if she was at the clubs every
weekend five years ago I mean you're
gonna get a couple bodies
again for five years you know like
that's a question for the late for all
of us yes yeah if if you tell the guy
your body count and he has an issue with
it does does that give you the ick I
feel like it does because why do you
care yeah also if you ask them because I
guarantee you because I've talked to
people about body accounts before at the
age of 18 now there's so many guys that
is double what mine is like I think I
thought yeah I don't think it should
matter because the people that get the
most are the ones that trust they have
so many more than you okay no no guys
guys what do you think Paul no I I think
that it matters it absolutely matters
and every data you look at the more the
more guys you sleep with the more likely
you are to be divorced really yeah and
okay if you and there's a couple
different studies so the numbers vary a
little bit but one there's one study
where if you slept if you're a virgin
when you get married you have an 80
chance of a happy marriage in 10 years
80 and you know what it drops to After
Five Guys which most men pray for
nowadays 25 chance of being happily
married after 10 years so and then
people will you know there's other
studies that it's 50 40 30 of whatever
it is but the most happy tend to be the
virgins who's trying to marry a virgin
though really interesting yeah
they've got no experience yeah that's
why I'm the teacher
that's what you've damaging
I know we have to go to the extremes to
like to prove the point because
historically men had to give me a virgin
men had to ensure paternity so they had
to know am I am I passing on resources
to a kid that's mine because
historically we didn't have paternity
tests we didn't have DNA tests so the
only way they could decipher that is is
this woman pure how does she act how is
she modest et cetera et cetera et cetera
but you know going back to it I I really
don't think that you can hide it for you
can only hide it for so I'm surprised
how many men are still not doing DNA
tests you know what I'm saying a lot of
men are not doing them because you know
our man's told us these kids
you see the things you see the things
that Jamaican guy said this he said
listen any man could have a kid you
don't need to breed a girl because a
woman get pregnant and tell you the kids
is yours you don't know if the kids did
the woman said it's yours and you're
like yeah man you take the kid you move
on Nicki that's what I'm saying you
don't have the kids are we talking about
Jamaican men okay
you can't talk about yourself because
not because we [ __ ] you down you gave
it to us because my dad is Jamaican and
I'm around a lot of Jamaican men and I
know a lot of Jamaican men who have a
bag of Pitney yeah
you know I might be a sailor I know what
you mean I know a [ __ ] yeah Twitter
you're getting on to me oh you should
have kids yeah I'm saying what man I got
this much kids you had a pair of twins
twins swab them wasn't his but that was
it for a minute I see let's bring moms
back into this let's bring moms back
into this this is where moms come in
handy okay more often than not your mom
would be the first one that's the DNA
test
your mom will tell you I don't know
about it I don't know about that one you
know you see the one that you know with
the claim your mom will tell you listen
that one's one of yours yeah trust me
your mom's a DNA test me yeah especially
in the Jamaican Community
your mom will tell you your mama told
you before you know before your girl
knows yeah yeah your mama said that
one's current as many
as many just banned on Tick Tock and we
are demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible